one month after he became only the third
u.s. president to be impeached formal
proceedings against Donald Trump have
begun in the US Senate within the past
hour the charges against him have been
read out in the Senate Trump is charged
with abuse of power for threatening to
withhold military aid to Ukraine in
exchange for a political favor he's also
charged with obstruction of Congress the
house managers of the US House of
Representatives outlined the charges
during an official reading of the
articles of impeachment the trial itself
is expected to start next week Donald J
Trump has abused the powers of the
presidency in that using the powers of
his high office President Trump
solicited the interference of a foreign
government Ukraine in the 2020 United
States presidential election he did so
through a scheme or course of conduct
that included soliciting the government
of Ukraine to publicly announce
investigations that would benefit his
reelection harm the election prospects
of a political opponent and influence
the 2020 United States presidential
election to his advantage let's go live
now to Capitol Hill Al Jazeera's Heidi
Joe Castro is there for us so Heidi
we're off talk us through what we saw
over the last hour or so that formal
walk of the house managers from the
house through to the Senate
that's right and it wasn't just the the
motion that they were going through
really that walk represents a key
threshold in this impeachment process
transferring the power of impeaching
President Trump from the US House of
Representatives which of course is the
Democratic controlled chamber and
transferring that power now to the
Senate a very different environment this
is where we have the Republican majority
which is of course President Trump's own
party they will conduct the trial of
President Trump and officially this
trial will kick off in just about an
hour's time that is when Chief judges
Justice John Roberts of the US Supreme
Court will be escorted into the Senate
chambers he will be administered and
oath to become the presiding officer of
this trial and then he will immediately
in turn swear in the 100 senators to
become the impartial jurist to decide
whether or not President Trump remains
in office
now that word impartial has been much
dissected in the sense because the very
leader of this body Mitch McConnell the
top Republican in the Senate he started
off by saying that he had no intention
of being impartial that he wanted he and
his members to defend the president and
his claim of innocence well regardless
they will be taking this oath and then
starting on next Tuesday that is when we
expect opening statements from both
sides
Democrats documenting what they say is
Trump's guilty actions of withholding US
security aid to Ukraine in order to
pressure its government to announce
investigations into Trump's political
opponents here in the US the president
has said he will send his attorneys to
defend him in those opening arguments
after that we don't know if they could
call for more witnesses that's something
that Democrats certainly want but they
won't have that happen without at least
some Republican support how do you many
thanks indeed let's separate a White
House correspondent Kimberly halket what
reaction if any has there been to all of
this from the White House Kimberly yeah
a couple of important tweets from the
White House press secretary Stephanie
Grisham who has said
in just the last half-hour obstruction
of Congress of course one of the
articles against the president she says
the speaker holding the articles for
four weeks before sending them to the US
Senate and the other article against the
president she responds to abuse of power
the house refusing to give the president
due process anyone noticed the Democrats
always accused POTUS that's President of
the United States of actions they
themselves are guilty of doing question
mark exclamation point it's safe to say
that the White House is doing what it
can to discredit the proceedings that
will kick off on Tuesday we expect in
the US Senate
Stephanie Grisham the White House press
secretary also trying to get out there
in the headlines what should have been a
shining moment for the US president
that's the passage of a major trade deal
that he renegotiated with Mexico and
Canada to replace NAFTA that allowed for
many manufacturing jobs to evaporate in
this country it was a major campaign
promise it also got passed in the US
Senate a but no one's talking about it
except the press secretary who writes
after yesterday's historic trade deal
with China and the u.s. MCA passed today
the Dems are now reading their sham
articles of impeachment which they
manufactured she says in order to stop
real Donald Trump from his conceit
continued success on behalf of the
United States
he's working there whining so again some
of sort of that nasty language being
used to try and discredit the process
that is going on in the US Senate
against US president Donald Trump on
White House correspondent Kimberly
halket live for us there in Washington
Alan Barron is a former special
impeachment counsel to the House of
Representatives he was involved in the
impeachment and removal of for federal
judges Allen joins us now live from
Washington Alan are those articles of
impeachment manufactured as the press
secretary claims no they are all based
on the evidence that was presented in
the house indeed with regard to the both
articles there's really no dispute as to
the fact I don't think anybody has an
illusions that as to whether or not the
facts that are alleged in the articles
whether in fact those are true what it's
really going to boil down
is to raw political power in the Senate
who has the votes but there's no
ambiguity as to what the facts are in
both instances so what sort of trial
will this be will Republican senators be
impartial as they were required in fact
they will swear an oath to be the answer
is no they may may they have the fig
leaf so to speak of the oath but even
though they may not have committed
themselves ahead of time as to how
they're going to vote we can expect that
there were only few if any defections
from the Republican ranks on the merits
it is perhaps unfortunate that the oath
that they take really puts them in this
difficult position but reality tells you
that their positions are pretty well
fixed before they hear one word of
evidence and what do you think of the
the articles of impeachment themselves
when they were read out by by Adam
Schiff well they're they're very
powerful I mean it was very solemn the
way mr. Schiff presented them and anyone
listening to that who had not completely
prejudged that this was all you know a
sham and and and should not be taking
place you had to be impressed with the
effects that were being laid out there
that this really goes to the heart of
the presidency at the power of the
presidency to engage a foreign
government with regard to the first
article and to use that relationship for
his own political purposes and the
second article which has taken sort of a
backseat a little bit but in fact it
subverts the entire constitutional
process of impeachment
it basically says you can't Stonewall
the house when it's trying to carry out
its constitutional duty and that is the
essence of what the second article
alleges and what about today's
revelation that an associate of the
president's own lawyer has been saying
that that the president was only
was with all too aware of what was going
on is that going to make any difference
well if the Republicans do not allow new
testimony new evidence to come in I
think they will do that at their peril
they may not pay for it here in this
proceeding in this impeachment trial but
I believe they will pay for it at the
ballot box in November there's a large
group of potential voters who are
watching this proceeding they haven't
made up their minds they want to hear
what the evidence is and if one side
stone walls and there's no better word
for it they prevent that evidence from
being presented to the American people
it's hard to believe that they will not
pay a very heavy price for trying to put
pull the wool over the American
electorate good to talk to you sir mr.
Baron many thanks indeed for being with
us